you talking about John Stewart I mean
I'm just saying like they just cast
fillian is like you know what I mean
like I just I see things wait he got
cast as to he got cast his how but like
the older how that's like retired and it
looks like they're kind of doing that
where they're going to layer it a bit
really look
at I still live in Tucson what's wrong
with Tucson there's one gay bar and it's
full of college kids one of them asked
me if I was Tyler Perry I mean Tyler
Perry lives in Atlanta right
welcome everyone to the awards tour
podcast I'm jacquell and Coy we're here
for our interview portion with an Emmy
sag and Golden Globe winner he is of
course Mr Sterling K Brown many of you
know him from his incredible performance
as Randall Pearson on this is us we're
here to talk to him today about American
fiction where he plays a character I
think I've been waiting my entire career
to see you play really it was so
incredibly perfect but I do want to
start here because this movie has
already won the audience prize at the
Toronto Film Festival but more than that
I do think it sort of caps off this
interesting sort of like 5year period
with you where I think after all that
crying they made you do on This Is Us
you made a conscious effort to just have
some fun between like you know Brooklyn
99 I mean even something like uh honk
for Jesus save your soul uh Artemis like
Hotel Artemis all these things I feel
like you were just like I have to do
something different with my time outside
of the show was that true I think so I
mean you can only make people cry so
much before you start to wonder like am
I doing a good thing do I need to bring
bring balance to the force cuz I know I
know I'm humorous uh that I have a sense
of humor I like to share that with
people as much as I love to share my
sense of paos with people right um and I
think even if you pay attention to
Randall he's pretty funny too sometimes
his funny comes out of a place of pain
or a desire to be wanted or needed and
like make himself bigger so that he
doesn't feel as if someone could discard
him right um but like sometimes it's
just good to make people laugh it's good
to allow people to release and that
release can happen through tears it can
happen through laughter sure many other
ways but those are the two that I know
we tend to elicit in terms of this art
form and I love when folks come up to me
and they say like dude that was really
funny I think the thing that folks
really saw where you really leaned into
that comedy that I I loved was SNL and
Brooklyn 99 like those two moments seem
so singular in their efforts but when I
was getting ready to do this interview
that was the thing that a lot of people
talked about if they didn't mention this
is us thank you very much yo i k SNL was
a blast yeah and I it's a word too
because I think the secret of anybody
that that does it they make you so tired
that by the time you're at Saturday
night you're like okay let's just go
let's just make it happen like literally
you're saying lines and you finish a
woman grabs your arm pulls you off stage
and people just start undressing you and
putting clothes like all right go and
you're like okay what the Q cards and
but that sort of energy because being on
it's like being on stage or whatnot you
get sort of caught up in the energy in
the audience Etc and knowing like you
can just feel the spirits of everybody
else that has been on that stage
throughout history it's like God dang I
get to be up here where Eddie was you
know what I'm saying not too long after
that again you know yeah yeah yeah so it
was it was awesome and I appreciate you
saying that I was funny thank you no I
mean it was really it was a great moment
because like when I looked at American
fiction the reason why I said it was a
role that I was hoping that you would
play because this character and again
and granted I will say this it's it's
part of a a larger story and he but when
he shows up he just steals every scene
and it's partially because yes he's
funny yeah but also there is a pain and
A Soulful that is that is masked in it
and it's like it was the perfect balance
of the two whereas I felt Randall's more
serious with some funny some other ones
are really funny and not as serious this
was that perfect sort of like 5050 split
thank you JC I appreciate that so talk
about this character and was that on the
page that way for him to be that
Duality I think so at least that's what
I saw when I read it right um I saw
someone who was middle-aged who was in
the closet
who just blew up his life after 20 years
of marriage being caught in bed with
another man and was in the midst of
finding what authentic expression felt
like on him right and I think to a large
extent that means being messy until you
know how to be neat in a new way um
because being neat and inauthentic
didn't work right trying to conform to
other people's perceptions of who he
should be didn't work and so now he's a
bit of a hot
mess and I'm gonna go ahead and say
ladies key emphasis on the word hot
check the trailer check the trailer
check the trailer I appreciate that but
but a bit of a hot mess in search of
what it looks like to be neat but
authentically so you know like from what
I understand about human nature and this
is me right now at 47 years old real
happiness isn't a possibility unless
you're really really willing to be
yourself whether other people accept you
or not and I think in youth the desire
to be accepted sometimes supersedes the
desire to be authentic to fit in we are
willing to twist ourselves in multitudes
of knots and even though we know we're
triangles
we're trying to fit into this square peg
right and you will do whatever it can to
to fit in there and then at a certain
point you're like oh this just doesn't
fit yeah right and you have to be
willing to endure the contempt or the
unacceptance of other people to just be
like well I don't the number of that are
given just dwindled to the fact that
like you know life experience has taught
you that being any other way doesn't
work right and I think we're in the
midst of seeing Cliff sort of figure out
what that new equilibrium is for himself
yeah and he does it with such again such
a such a pain but also such a humor like
he literally makes me cry the first
tears of the movie and the biggest
laughs of the movie it's absolutely
right there the thing that's also there
and I I would have to imagine it was a
huge part of why you signed on and also
something you probably want to discuss
with cord before signing on is it
definitely speaks to almost a meta
existence within our industry and
something that you've had to fight for
just as any black actor I think James
Baldwin said to exist as a conscious
black man is to be in a constant state
of anger because of just and Hollywood
does that as well was there something
about you that wanted to explore that
sort of idea of like let me laugh at
this thing that obviously I am sure
you've had to deal with at every chapter
of your career yeah I listen it is what
I enjoy about the script is that he's
talking about the limiting perceptions
that Cinema has had of us historically
and how that those limiting perceptions
can lead to uh how people see us in life
right to the point where if they see
someone who's not like that in life that
they've seen on Cinema they all say oh
you're not real black you're you're like
you're different than the others like
you're really smart you know what I mean
mean like you know you don't talk like
you know what I'm saying and they say
like you know what I'm saying like
you're you're like one of us and I'm
like no I'm still one of
them yeah and being one of them just
looks like more than what you've seen
yeah right and the other part of that is
too sometimes we have to take our own
sort of accountability in terms of how
we voted with our Dollar in terms of the
types of stories that get seen right we
will
as a community that we want like a wider
breath of expression right I remember
being younger things like uh an EES byou
which I thought was absolutely beautiful
yeah Casey lemons Casey lemons shout out
but did not necessarily get like the box
office love that I think that it
deserved and then the next DMX flick
shout out to DMX who has one of the
funniest scenes I have ever seen in top
five oh yes you know I'm talking Chris
Rock's top five where he goes around and
asks all the actors they top five
rappers but do you know DMX's team when
he has to that right there you got a
minute yeah check this
out smile though your heart is
aching smile even though it's
breaking when there are clouds in the
sky you'll get by smile through the pain
and sorrow what but I'm saying like the
earlier on like those movies would do
huge or whatnot and I'm like but people
would say we want to see this too we
like that but we want to see this too
and anytime this too came out people
didn't necessarily vote with their
dollar in a way that I think that they
could have I'm hoping in 2023 2024
people are of a new mind and being like
you know what if it's something that I
want to see I have the power to have
some sort of influence on it by by going
to see it because if it don't make
dollars it don't make sense like it has
to cross over into a mainstream sort of
thing in order for these Studios to be
like you know what this makes money like
it's not just great storytelling and
it's not just for that Community it's
great storytelling for the world and
it's just good business yeah it's good
business um I think one of the things
that this one is already done because it
has won countless audience Awards I
think we've got at least three counting
starting with Tiff which is a pretty
good marker of best picture so I'm sure
you heard that before but I think you
can already sort of say that with it
because the thing I loved about it is
Suburban black kids get their day in
this movie in a way and I feel like your
St Louis Roots cord sort of Boston roofs
that's a Synergy too because look
there's some people whose adolescence
looked more like The Cosby's in
comparison to good times and they
haven't really had that representation
since the COS right right listen you
could say blackish kind of gets get
there get you know that's like the the
highest level of Rich suburb black they
Prett high like I would say the black
Pier have like a little bit more of a
sort of Middle Road there um but it is
like I I I get tired you talking about
how racist it is when people say you're
not real black or whatnot and things
that I would hear towards the beginning
of my career in terms of like he's got
to kind of lose that intelligent thing
what have you as if as if to be that
meant that I wasn't being black right I
think we are learning to see ourselves
in a wider breath like not just them
seeing us but us seeing us right and
being able to Define blackness in a way
that is much more generous and I said
this before I think I think who is it
who's a comedian from insecure Amanda
Amanda was like the only way of being
not black is being anti-black yeah right
and I was like that works for me that
works that works for me if you trying to
tear down your community you I don't
need you in the community but other than
that we can draft another you know what
I'm saying other than that if you want
to go fly fishing or you know jeopardy
or whatever it is like come on bring it
bring it I I really do love this about
core too is he he's a television person
for folks that don't know he worked on
succession he worked on the leftovers
worked with you know a ton of really uh
he worked on um Watchman yeah one one
Emy he also assembled an incredible
group of I think Stellar television
actresses to support in this from Leslie
Uggams people don't know she was the
very first black woman to have a variety
special you're the very first black man
since uh however long to win for the for
best comedy like I think it was like 70
or 33 years something crazy like that
since the last black guy had went for
that I think that had to like weigh in
on the set because this Ensemble Erica
also Alexander from Living Single it was
was just such a Powerhouse and of course
Tracy we can't we can't even like diss
on that no it it it had to did you feel
it when you guys were filming this one
cuz I felt it watching it yeah I think I
felt it I think it's something I've also
hungered for like often times these
great ensembles don't get a chance to
get together because somebody's ego says
like oh I'm not going to be second
billing to whomever or whatnot like I
think I almost had a chance I was almost
in the the harder they fall but then Co
happened I didn't get a chance to be a
part of that but I love seeing like a
group of us play together right because
a lot of my career has been being the
black guy yeah oh who's the black guy in
that oh Sterling who the black guy in
that oh yeah Jeffrey like it's it's nice
when like the black guys and the black
girls all get a chance to get together
and play in the sandbox together yeah I
enjoy it and it's rare man it really is
rare so it's great to have one that has
been this successful so far just with
like both the critical acclaims soon
folks are going to get a chance to see
it in theaters all right now real talk
we've been talking for a few years I've
been covering for a while and I've never
felt as jealous as I did watching you
and Sean like I literally felt like I
was watching an ex with this new
girlfriend like it was it was it hurt a
little bit cuz I was like they got
chemistry too okay well like but I've
now learned that that may be bigger than
an Oscar for you like that literally is
like literally something that you have
dreamed about I'm I'm just now to
realize that like it may be like your
wife kids and and hot Ones hot on so so
I'm going tell you about friends of mine
have been watching it for a while and
they're like bro you got to go do hot
wings I was like what's the big deal
right so then you go down the rabbit
hole and you watch him and you want you
wonder like what's it going to be like
when I eat the wings like how's it going
to feel like I'm I'm a man I can do this
stuff right but then you start eating
them wings and that sh hit different it
is real different and you feel drunk and
you find yourself saying stuff that you
never
say but it's like he it's like that you
just took down a fifth of whiskey or
something you're like I'm just awful
hotness off some hot like it was insan
and I remember it was Wing seven you're
like I feel drunk
yeah it was but like it they listen it's
not just Sean too I just want to say
that no he got crew yes people are doing
background and whatnot and I appreciate
that they ask things that don't always
get asked but man it is such a surreal
feeling to be do it's like patting your
head and rubbing your belly at once
right so you can't be jealous because
it's a slightly different thing it's a
very different thing I can be jealous of
it also too because like I love Hot ones
too like I watched it when it was just
rappers like I remember like uh like
like early days you know what I mean and
that one so I'm a huge fan of it any ask
good questions I'm fan of anybody that
ask good questions like at least uh
respect the art form me he definitely
does for sure uh I'm going to like throw
this one out there too because I feel
like you're at a really great time where
you're just doing what you want yeah um
but you're also like still like working
and and and open to everything that
there is to be done and I remember man
and this been a while since you talked
about this but there's a new person over
at DC and are you talking about John
Stewart I mean I'm just saying like they
just cast feeling and is like you know
what I mean like I just I see things
wait who he got cast as who it he got
cast as how but like the older how
that's like retired and it looks like
they're kind of doing that where they're
going to layer it a bit really look
at listen I I I watched that Justice
League cartoon religiously in like high
school uh college right after Etc it was
dope
seeing John Stewart knowing that there
was a Black Lantern was something like
in terms of representation wise was like
oh man there's a space for me in this
world and I see it right and when I
would look at him like kind of look like
this cartoon know what I'm saying I
listen if it if it could happen that
would be legitimately exciting like that
would be one of those giddy inducing
moments in life
because my kids would sort of get it
like without me having to explain it to
them like most of the stuff I do I have
to explain yeah Daddy's doing the movie
it's a big deal they're like okay it's
not a big deal to me like my kid is like
yeah this is us great boohoo like it
doesn't care but like that would be Al
like look I I'm in Invincible right now
yes I can't even really take cuz like
Invincible this I was like you can't
show that to your K I was 12 I was just
about to ask you about Invincible
because the 12y old maybe one time I was
watching the boys and he goes what you
watching that I said I'm watching a TV
show called the boys and he's like can I
watch I was like you can give it a shot
and this black dude got his arm just
like hit and the car he's like yo what
are you doing like what you I was like
all clearly you're not ready for the boy
got to come back a little bit later um
but John
Stewart that's that's maybe I have to
talk to somebody because you gotta give
James a call it's funny that you
mentioned Invincible too because you
can't really talk about that one they're
right in the middle of your season and
your character is we don't know like
literally I'm like you could have to
keep this one a secret for you but can
you preview anything that you can tell
us about your character because right
now from what folks have seen they've
only seen like four episodes and it's
like right in the middle of cliffhanger
there's a lot angst from Ley he's got a
big head I have to learn how to do that
internalize internalize his head winds
up outside of his body it's funky I tell
you what's fun about doing these these
voiceover things in cartoon it's because
they'll show you like the animation or
show you like ideas of what the
animation is going to look like and so
they sort of come close to who you are
as a person like my man's always got his
goatee or what not I'm like that's cool
and then when I showed his brain outside
his head you're like ow I can't do that
in real life so it's it's like there's a
voice that you start to explore that's
slightly different than your own because
there's a physical manifestation that
you're not capable of in life that you
can now be capable of in animation and
it's exciting right it's also I'm always
talking about being a bad guy like I
like the idea of being a bad guy and
he's a bad guy who's not always bad kind
of killmonger resque in that way and so
there's complexity to him and you can't
just outright vilify him cuz every once
in a while he'll land with a point
you'll be like oh
like Thanos was like this world is too
big and sometimes I go Thanos might be
right stuck you're stuck on the 405 on
the wrong day you said was right talk to
me J real I'm so GL it's like you're
reading my mind because I I felt very
bad with you on the initial black
panther run yeah because you were in it
it couldn't say nothing even after it
came out like that had to be one of the
weirdest situations you're in one of the
biggest movies on the planet but in the
effort to not spoil it right you really
don't get to have a moment with what
ends up being a such a pivotal character
in later chapters of this entire movie
yeah and joobu you know he was he was an
important part of the plot but they
wanted to keep it a secret I think being
on this is us for the many years I was
like I know how to keep a secret cuz
fogman is real serious with his secrets
too and you don't want to get on the
wrong side of the MCU let me DC MCU you
go show up to work yeah they give you
your sides for the day and then they
take that back if you did forget to give
it to him there's a young uh blonde girl
of 26 years age she's like that's okay
I'll wait outside here until you get it
and you're like you going to sit there
like Children of the Corn until I give
you these Pages she's like it's
fine that is her cuz that's on her she
can't walk back with nothing in her hand
say and then you go and you look in your
your room and you're like oh found and
she like thank you so much I see you
later she's like
G so in terms of just keeping things
under wraps you understand how important
it is and you don't want to be the one
that lets the cat out of the bag fair
right like that's the bottom line I was
like somebody may find out you ain't
finding out from your boy yeah yeah I
did love to see in the sequel they put
kilmonger in the same place that you
were in when he visited you just that
moment moment and I was like this is
like Echoes of joob like still it's good
stuff it's really great stuff all right
last question because I do have to say
this because I really love this about
your family you are a working actor
family like a legitimate one both you
and your wife are what I consider like
television film everywhere in between
working actors how much was the love
strengthen or hurt when y'all were
sitting at home staring at each other
during the
stride cuz y'all were like I don't know
if you two have spent that much time we
had a lot of quality time with these two
little children that we have so that
gave us a lot of love um but I think
both of us are looking forward to
getting back to work we're going to do a
podcast ourselves as a matter of fact so
we found a project that I think besides
just our children which are our mutual
project we have something to pour into
um that sort of excites us so that was
born out of it and hopefully that will
be a good thing I love that y'all do
that thank you so much uh anything you
want to shout out podcast let us keep an
eye out for it yeah it come out sometime
around Valentine's Day and it is
tentatively toddled we don't always
agree with Ryan and Sterling oh I love
this so much all right folks be on
lookout for that Sterling thank you so
much